region Colombia store to the Amazon
rainforest it was relatively safe from
deforestation until 2016. but when the
peace process with the leftist gorillas
known as the farc was signed the fires
and bulldozers started to multiply
everywhere
but environmentalists
things started to change last year
there is a change in government and they
say the environment is a main priority
the possibility of changes in land laws
and land distribution has generated
expectations and are at the roots of
conflict
we travel to talk to those affected by
War and who are trying to help fight
deforestation which in the past year was
reduced by nearly 30 percent 50 000
hectares of land was spared for the
first time in years the government of
Petra is trying to implement what is
known as a total peace plan with several
of the Armed groups that continue to
operate in areas like this one in
Colombia it is right now negotiating a
peace agreement with a National
Liberation Army a guerrilla organization
where for the first time the environment
is part of the agreement in an attempt
to put an end to the destruction of
Colombia's forests
even though a peace agreement was signed
with farc Rebels dissident groups
continue to control this area
and in the town of Tortuga they ordered
people to gather to discuss their
contribution to the rebel group
people here tell us the gorillas have
banned all sorts of deforestations since
president took office in an attempt to
secure a peace dialogue with the
government
they come and tell us do not destroy and
that we need to care for the environment
of course we are afraid there's also
this mentality that if we don't stop
destroying the forest the forest will
destroy us
for several years different
administrations have implemented
productive reconversion programs
Marta Galiano is part of a group that
makes pastries oil and other products
with fruits from the Amazon
we do not have the resources to reforest
but we are going to preserve many of
those who cut down trees do it because
it's part of their livelihood and that
is what has started to change
everyone here knows that peace and the
small triumphs in reducing deforestation
in the past year are fragile
they say the government and
international support are crucial right
now to make them last
Colombia
foreign